dieu plutôt désordonné d'
accord d'
accord tu es un peu gros maintenant
reviens
voir
euh j'ai commencé instagram était juste pour euh
garder un blog de ses activités quotidiennes
parce qu'elle était vraiment mignonne d'une certaine manière
et voulait juste capturer ces moments
et
et elle a commencé  grandir en
attirant beaucoup de gens qui la suivent,
je pense qu'il y avait cette poussée naturelle
vers les ventes en ligne, vous savez, comme
les plateformes en ligne comme les marchés et
tout et avec tous ces marchés
étant extrêmement agressifs avec la façon dont
ils approchent les consommateurs, beaucoup de
marques commencent  reconnaître
qu'il est important d'avoir une présence numérique
et avec cela, vous le savez, en particulier pour
les entreprises d'aliments pour animaux de compagnie, car elles
rechercheraient naturellement des influences pour animaux de compagnie pour
parler de leurs produits afin de générer des ventes, du
trafic ou de la sensibilisation, c'est là que
nous entrons en jeu d'
accord